yeah I did get kicked out of Sunday
School uh that shit's on my resume
my dad was the choir director
at uh saint rayfield's Cathedral where
I'm from it's Saint Raphael's
but if you're
if you're from Wisconsin it's
I just found this out I just realized
this
I just realized that it was only because
we were in Wisconsin that we pronounced
it Ray Fields
I'm sorry
did you mean Raymond feel
yeah Ray Fields
yeah like it's a sports bar come on down
to Ray Fields
two for ones on admonishments this week
free drinks not just on Sundays anymore
come on down Ray Fields why watch the
game when you can be where it's decided
the good guys always win it Ray Fields
thank you